do you think because you're from
missouri that like you're just always
going to be a missouri girl like you're
going to be a small town kind of girl
you're not going to be an la girl even
though you moved to l.a yeah no i mean i
one of the good things about the way my
career one of the good things and the
weird things is my first record came out
when i was 29 right so i'd already been
a school teacher i'd already had jobs
like real jobs in the real workforce
yeah i love your story like you were
engaged when you lived in missouri like
you were gonna live like a very sort of
crack research team here yeah you were
engaged to a guy and you were a teacher
what did you teach i taught elementary
music in the st louis public school
system did you have to go to college for
uh i did i got my degree in classical
piano performance in education can you
imagine if you hadn't had the balls to
sort of say goodbye to the balls to say
goodbye to the fiancee and to say
goodbye to school teaching
because at the time you're making what
18 grand as a school teacher making 17
grand now the story i heard is while
you're still being a teacher you went in
on an audition for like a mcdonald's
commercial or something and you landed
it yes and and um that had to be like if
that like just landing a mcdonald's
commercial you could have stopped your
career right then it would have been
impressive i don't know the t yeah like
i did i was playing in a band and this
guy who was doing session work in town
came in and said will you come in and
sing this commercial and it was regional
he did a lot of stuff that was out of
chicago chicago is a big mecca for doing
commercials and then it got picked up
regionally and then it went network and
it was i had to do the voice of aunt b
like they had me do all these voices
singing um e-i-e-i-o
it was like a farm thing do you remember
it oh yeah
e-i-e-i-o and how to do like yeah like a
marilyn monroe and then the whole thing
ended with it's a good time for the
great days to mcdonald's
and it went and i made forty-two
thousand dollars you're saying more than
two two years of teaching you sang the
jingle
you do all the voices from mcdonald's
this commercial is national therefore
over the course of the year you make
forty two thousand dollars in checks and
you're like what the [ __ ] am i doing
teaching i mean it's a noble
professional yeah a famous jingle singer
is that what gave you the impetus do you
have to turn to your fiance and say
listen uh dude we had split yeah we
actually we split after we moved to st
louis and i started teaching we split do
you ever have nightmares like that you
just didn't have the vision to go to la
and become a singer that that like
you're just like still married to that
guy and and you i don't but i do on
occasion have dreams where i'm teaching
in front of a bunch of kids and like i'm
tearing my hair out did you like what
that means did you hate it no i didn't
hate it you know i've never hated one
thing in my life right yeah i've never
been like i had the wherewithal or the
presence to think i hate this when you
went to l.a yes was it a nightmare for
you i mean filled with anxiety
are you are you sitting there go are you
thinking i'm gonna set the world on fire
right away i never never none of it ever
occurred to me i have people saying
did you always know you're going to be
famous right never thought that far in
advance how did you make money when you
first got to la
um i did what everybody else does i
waited tables oh you were a waitress
yeah where the hell are you waitress
well i was waitressing in the valley at
a place called la cafe yeah and one of
the reasons i got a job there was that's
where all the musicians came like the
the legit the ones that i would read
their names on my albums right
and um so i was doing some jingles first
thing i did when i got to la is i took
my my demo tape to every studio
got my thomas guide you know there was
no cell phone no navigation got my
thomas guide went to every studio but
what was the on the demo tape was it
just covers of other people's stuff i've
done some commercials in st louis like i
did enough commercials and then i did a
few demo songs
that somebody else wrote took it around
and i started getting called
got a job at la cafe gave that cassette
to a musician who came in that i knew
did jingles
and the next day he called me
and hired me to do a national toyota
spot
and i got fired for giving my tape out
because i wasn't supposed to do that but
because you gave it out at la cafe i got
it yeah so
yeah i got that gig and that gig must
have paid pretty well so that paid 67
thousand dollars oh my god
i remember these little numbers because
big because those numbers are real they
meant something are you kidding me yeah
i mean once my car had a boot on it
i remember that and i was having to cab
to work so i got to pay my car off i
mean stuff like that isn't that such a
weird business like you get one stupid
commercial and you've got 67 dollars and
back then you were like oh my god i
could live on this i mean i could
actually did and you sure did yeah